the next artists we salute are the Lords
of the lenss the crusty poets called
cinematographers who say rude things to
actors while making love to them with
lights presenting the awards will be
Doctor Zhivago
and the girl who popped the mercury out
of his thermometer here are an Margaret
and Omar Sharif
Oh welcome and Margaret is a true you
were born in Sweden that's right Bob and
Omar you're from Egypt yes and you I
think were born in England right right
is everett dirksen the only native left
in show business
all right and Margaret let's begin by
reading out the names of the nominees
for the best
black-and-white cinematography Joseph
Nichelle for the fortune cookie Ken
Higgins for George Egan my son Daniel
for his Paris burning James won't have
four seconds Haskell Wexler for Who's
Afraid of Virginia Woolf to make a
presentation please the winner is
Haskell Wexler
I hope I hope we can use our art for
peace and for love thanks
remedies for Best Cinematography of a
picture filmed in color uh Russell
Harlan for Hawaii
Ted more for a man for all seasons
Joseph McDonald for the sand pebbles
come at home for the professionals and
Ernest Laszlo for Fantastic Voyage you
announced this way to Omaha okay the
winner is dead more for the man for all
seasons
for Tet mores mr. Howell boy
I'm terribly sorry that I'm the wrong
more I spelled my name differently than
Ted but I just like to say for him as I
know he would like to say that thank you
for this terrific honor that you have
bestowed upon him I only wish that I
could share with him directly
I hope Sherif hurries out to the parking
lot his camel is eating the straw seat
covers off of an Margaret's motorcycle